and here we
go
hello everybody i'm jeff keely and this
is summer game fest a live showcase of
what's next in the wide wide world of
video games we are live here in los
angeles whether you're streaming from
home or watching inside an imax theater
welcome to our showcase event over the
next few hours we'll give you updates on
the games you love be joined by special
developer guests and yes have a few
surprises along the way too now what i
love about this show is that it's a true
cross industry showcase whether you play
on xbox pc playstation switch or mobile
will have games for you it doesn't
matter your platform of choice we're all
here to come together as one community
that simply loves the art of amazing
video games
the biggest franchises in the industry
are here like call of duty you'll get
introduced to exciting new worlds new
teams and will make room for small
independent developers who we think
deserve the spotlight too if we do this
right hopefully you'll discover a few
new games to put on your wish list and
even if you don't get every announcement
that you desire let's face it you're not
going to get everything today but we've
got a lot of great stuff so let's get
started
over 30 years ago capcom street fighter
hit arcades and ever since this
legendary japanese fighting game series
has continued to evolve street fighter 6
is coming in 2023 and right now we're
excited to officially confirm a
character coming to the game and show
you the exclusive first gameplay footage
enjoy
[Music]
you will know what hit you
let me have some fun
let's get this mission started
got you in my sights
god
perfect
predictable time to end this
i'm just on another level
[Music]
it's all about the comb all right next
it's time for a brand new game
announcement here at summer game fest
check this out
[Music]
sergeant leo alvarez of the cmle recon
squad
our mission was to enter the tantalus
space locate the comsat relay and bring
it back online
we found the relay
but there was a
problem
get that door closed now private
what we found was
a new kind of evil
and it found us first
what
this
wasn't human
retreat
through that door
i don't know what i saw in there
but i know when i close my eyes
i still see it
now everyone's dead
and someone needs to know
that was aliens dark descent and it's
coming in 2023 to console and pc
next two years ago at the game awards we
revealed the callisto protocol from the
creative forces behind the dead space
franchise today i am thrilled to get to
show you the first raw game play
alongside its creator glenn schofield
but first here's the quote-unquote
scofield cut of the brand new trailer
with a little more gore
[Music]
take a look outside
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
so whatever you're holding on to right
there
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your
life
is entirely
in my hands
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
[Music]
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time
[Applause]
welcome
to your new home
[Music]
that's right we know what you wanted to
see and joining me now glenn scofield
striking distance glenn uh first of all
congratulations this game looks
absolutely incredible and i gotta say
the fact that you have built this team
this studio new ip shipping this
december all in covid blows me away so
congratulations yeah thanks man uh
thanks for having us i really do
appreciate it jeff um and you know for a
second just give me a second
you know i want to thank you uh for all
you've done for the game industry uh all
these years man i i think i've known you
like 16 17 years now and uh
you've been an ambassador
um you've amplified new games new
studios and uh i just wanted to thank
you i really do appreciate it thank you
it's not about me it's about you guys
yeah i know i appreciate that thank you
so much and yeah it's so fun to do these
shows and to show this game so people
saw the trailer but what i'm so excited
today is that you just brought a raw
gameplay sequence this game is in
development and people can be blown away
i think when they see it but tell us a
bit about what are we going to see today
yeah we got a couple minutes of uh like
you said like we're all game play um
it's two segments in the first half of
the game uh one is a med bay another one
is a power station and you're gonna see
uh some
new enemies some brutality some uh just
about everything we we're showcasing a
new uh weapon called the grip it's a
like a gravity gun but it picks up the
enemies and it shoves them into giant
fans it rips them apart it's great and
uh and then check out the uh
the nice ending we have where we uh you
know we usually will kill our main
character jacob and in a very unique way
and uh
uh just for a second i i want to thank
the team man like you said through covid
through everything else the dedication
the hard work uh you guys are amazing
thank you very much oh well glenn i
gotta say again you know what you guys
are shipping this year this looks like a
world-class next-gen game uh it's it's
rare that teams are bringing something
out like this this year and
let's let the footage speak for itself
schofield striking distance here it is
the first gameplay of the callisto
protocol
what's going on
oh
foreign
uh
[Music]
so
oh my god
that just happened all right moving on
this october call of duty modern warfare
2 arrives infinity ward is once again
returning to its roots for a modern day
action game and today we're about to
show you the world premiere of its game
play with a level play through to tell
us more let's head to the port of long
beach to check in with johanna ferris
the head of call of duty
hi everyone in 2019 modern warfare
changed everything and on october 28th
we usher in a new era of call of duty
with the launch of modern warfare 2. we
are back we are bigger and we are
bringing the entire team
price
gaz soap alejandro
and of course ghost we needed a stage
big enough to debut call of duty in a
whole new way
inspired by the world we're about to
enter
oil rigs cargo ships and staggering odds
are just the beginning
here is modern warfare 2.
[Music]
this could be a trap
we're set
guppy get to work
all shadows that this was on this
platform
i want full containment
cut right clear through
room clear coming out
channel one moving to the southeastern
[Music]
12.
[ __ ] door
we're moving to the main deck what's
your status boarding the ship with
shadow three now roger
we need to move fast all shadows force
out i want eyes on that container now
two coffees going
we gotta roll
they're gonna launch that missile
it's first stage there's no
shadows time on the helm pad
2-1 we're moving in secure
move to the halifax
[Music]
clear
on that damn ship
actually we got a problem
on the ship you have your orders son
stop that launch
[Music]
fast secure those controls stop this
vessel yeah how do we board
take the ramp
all night
let's have ourselves a gunfight
missile patrols are on the bridge
have to stop the lawn
copy that
reloading
oh
between them
[Music]
check your corner
[Music]
this
on bridge entry
three two one execute
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta
that's what we're talking about and
joining us now up from long beach
johanna great to see you how's
everything it's great thanks uh great to
have you with us and also jeff from uh
infinity ward so
we saw the first gameplay thanks for
that extended sequence looks incredible
uh jeff tell us a bit about that mission
uh where is that set in the game what
are we seeing there absolutely so um
first of all we're really excited to
welcome back uh captain john price and
uh
uh gaz uh garrick um
you know they're not they're not
actually in what we just saw today but
uh they're returning members from 141
and then the other two characters uh
that were you may recognize from the
older franchise that we're reimagining
are uh simon ghost riley and uh of
course uh soap john mctavish um and then
a couple other new characters in here
that we're really excited uh that we got
to uh create for this game um first uh
commander philip graves and uh mexican
special forces uh colonel alejandro and
alejandro i guess they were it's a
character we're really excited about
he's a guy who's super capable and a guy
uh who's just as important as test
course 141 um but as far as the level is
concerned um you know this i got a shout
out to iw you know this was a tremendous
collaboration across all of the the
different uh disciplines as you saw
everybody coming together some really uh
motivated devs here and uh you know you
saw the the wind and the uh animations
and the awesome sound design and of
course our new water tech which is
actually pushing the boat in different
directions it's creating a physically
dynamic environment allowing for the
cover you were seeing in certain cases
you could be behind cover and then
suddenly that cover would shift and
leave you exposed but it also leaves the
enemy exposed creating this emergent
gameplay um so again i'm i'm very
excited just can't wait that i'm so
excited that we get to show it off today
and that's just a hint of where things
are going to go
johanna tell us a bit about call of duty
overall modern warfare 2 obviously you
know we're so excited that it's back
this year but you've got lots going on
across quality what can we expect from
you guys this year yeah we um first of
all thanks for having us here we're just
so excited for october 28th
it's such a big moment not just for
modern warfare 2 and everything that
jeff and the team at infinity ward have
built but it really marks the step
change what we're calling a
transformational moment for the entire
franchise you're going to see incredible
rendering incredible graphics all the
things just within the game itself built
all on one shared engine now across war
zone and modern warfare 2 going forward
of course there's a lot of chatter and
interest about the new war zone
experience we're affectionately calling
it war zone 2.0
there will be
a stand-alone experience of war zone for
current existing
players as well so we're going to sort
of feed the entire community there but
all eyes on the 28th
and again i think the collaboration's
just been incredible everybody's so
excited for task force 141
warzone coming to mobile as well for
players on the go we're on steam as you
know i mean so it's just a big moment
and there's going to be a lot more to
come in the in the months to follow
well before we we leave we got to ask a
little bit about war zone 2 i know we
just you know we're showing gameplay
here on this but can you tell us
anything there's a little it seems like
there's a little bit of a tease maybe in
the trailer yesterday yeah when we're
seeing that from the community we love
when the fans can pick up some things um
some chatter about maybe seeing high
rise and other elements but we will get
into the details of war zone 2.0 for
sure it will be an extension of the
modern warfare 2 universe so all the
more reason why we think this game this
moment is is such an important title for
all of us looking looking ahead and like
we said we're having a bold vision
around the entire future for the
franchise so we're in we're in position
we're really excited all right well
we're looking forward to october thanks
so much for giving us a first look at
the game play call of duty modern
warfare 2. thanks johanna and jeff
all right well we've got lots more
summer game fest still to go and now
it's time to announce a classic pc
gaming franchise is coming back with a
sequel over 30 years after its first
release i love this game when i was
growing up so i'm honored to share this
very first look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's turn back time back in
2017 we announced which fire at the game
awards almost five years later i am so
excited the team at the astronauts in
poland has put together an in-depth look
at the gameplay of this dark fantasy
first person shooter which will enter
early access soon i am so excited to
play this and i bet you will be too
after you see this
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
okay next up comes an ambitious new game
from a new independent studio in europe
starring some very familiar names enjoy
this world premiere new game
announcement
[Music]
officer taylor medlog
29.
today um
i can't believe what i saw
solace
everything okay in there
[Music]
ah
something's going on here
and i need to find out what it is
that's something brand new and look who
it is troy and roger in person guys uh
this is so fun the fact that you're
working on a game together what a cool
team up uh welcome to the show uh good
to be here i gotta ask you guys uh who
are your characters in this game well i
get to play a character named wyatt
taylor as a medical officer who's
stationed at this base fort salas
and it's the epicenter of this mystery
that we'll discover and uncover as we go
through the game and of course my
character will be at times in opposition
with
roger's character
the battle we've been waiting to see
yeah oh man we can't wait to show you
what we've been working on and by the
way jeff this looks awesome man it's so
great to be here thanks for having us
it's so great that you're in another
game we i mean it's feeling this is your
first game since the red dead one of the
first major ones for a while and i play
a character by the name of jack leary
he's a maintenance engineer on a remote
martian mining post
his job is to make sure that none of the
equipment breaks down while it's on
their graveyard shift the graveyard
shift meaning mars and earth are really
far apart from each other and their
orbits around the sun so help is not a
simple call away
uh i gotta ask i think a lot of people
will see this thing and they'll probably
wonder
you know it's a new team right uh you
know independent studio in europe that's
making this but with huge production
values i'm curious like how did you guys
get attached to this tell us a bit about
the background i i will say that 2020 to
me was the most impactful year for games
it was the first i mean obviously we had
this unprecedented event with a pandemic
and that forced the way that we looked
at everything as a society but also the
way this industry functioned it was also
brand new consoles we had more tools
that were being made available that were
leveling the playing field between like
the aaa studios and the indie stews of
the triple eye studios and so just like
anybody else we got reached out james
tinsdale with this brand new studio said
we'd like for you to
consider being a part of this game and
he walked me through a very brief
description of what the experience was
going to be like and
at the very beginning he said
it's we want this to feel it's a it's a
tight thriller we want it to feel like
dead space meets uh duncan jones moon
and i was like sign me up i'm into that
absolutely and full like performance
capture and everything oh yeah
absolutely new studio brand new energy
and of course
i get to work with one of the best of
the business and me i get the privilege
who's the other getting to see this guy
and watch him in action i know i love to
work and i love the challenges and all
the new innovations that this medium
provides to performers we can't wait to
show you what we've been working on i
think it's going to know i guess i've
seen some of the behind the scenes and
the performance capture unreal engine 5
i mean this is it looks absolutely
phenomenal can you give us a hint about
the the gameplay like what are we going
to do in this game yeah the verbs are
always important so we're going to let
the game speak for itself we'll be
showing you more later on but uh this is
a game where you as the player you're
going to be exploring you're going to be
discovering like we said it's a very
tight thriller so you're moving very
fast pace through this world you'll be
multiple locations multiple ways for you
to traverse which we're excited to show
you about uh and then the the narrative
is a huge element to this the they they
didn't waste uh any any resources on the
the performance for sure i got to tell
one quick story if i can um that was one
of our favorite moments um
there is a lot of action in this game
and that was at the the forefront of
this
and to speak to the performance capture
aspect we brought in an incredible i
gotta give him a shout out to nathaniel
our stunt coordinator who walked us
through and really approached this in a
completely different way than anything
i've ever done before and he says i want
to know the story of this fight and so
roger and i sat down we said these are
our characters are and he goes give me
one hour and i will come back to you
with the story of this fight and after
an hour he comes to us and he goes it
was like a like a recovery program it
was 12 steps and he walked us through
this incredible fight
about halfway out halfway through i
started tuning him out and i was like
hey man i just want you know i've got no
ego about this but i can do a lot of
things but i i can't do this and he
grabbed me by my shoulders and he says
oh you can you will and it's going to be
glorious and we did and we did dance it
was a lot of trust and it worked out
yeah i mean we're excited
yeah i mean this is so cool to see is it
an independent studio doing this teaming
up with you guys we can't wait to see
more troy roger thanks for joining us
here happy to be here thank you all
right appreciate very much guys all
right well next up keeping up with the
space team it's time to world premiere a
very exciting new game which will
feature a musical score by industry
legend mick gordon this one is gonna
grab you and we are so honored to debut
it
[Music]
so
so
[Applause]
[Music]
doesn't that look great that was routine
coming to xbox and pc it was first
announced a decade ago and is now
officially back i can't wait to see more
now it's time to check in with a very
special guest who's been in his fair
share of video games including most
recently fortnite as the foundation
dwayne johnson welcome to summer game
fest how are you
what's up everybody and what's up jeff
and what is up to the
summer game fest audiences live
streaming right now around the world and
everybody inside the epic imax theaters
dwayne johnson here coming at you from
my iron paradise the very hot
and sweaty
smelly iron paradise uh powered by of
course zoa energy the number one fastest
growing energy drink in the game you
guys know me uh by a lot of nicknames
the rock
la roca in spanish uh uncle handsome
sexiest man alive uh big drink energy
always room for a cheesy joke there's
always room for the extra large cheese
pizza especially when i'm delivering and
i deliver them often
you guys also know me as the
greatest and most electrifying surprise
in gaming that happened you know me as
the foundation
and i got to tell you guys uh number one
thank you so much for the crazy response
of me becoming the foundation but also
i got to say that you know i've had such
a pleasure uh working with um epic games
and uh the teams over there and we
cannot wait to show you what we have in
store for the future and speaking of the
future in the future you will also know
me as black adam
black adam as millions of you know
around the world who know the black out
of mythology he is ruthless he is
unstoppable and for those who don't i
always like to say a quick tutorial is
this
um black adam has the powers of superman
but the only difference well there's a
few differences but one of the biggest
differences is superman's weakness is
magic and black adam's one of his
superpowers is magic
so you do the math uh october 21st i
cannot wait for you guys to see black
adam around the world in theaters only
and you guys will finally see the
hierarchy of power in the dc universe
change uh it has been an honor to become
black adam and it was a
it is a role that's in my dna and that i
was born to play i was born to play the
man in black and i'm honored to show it
to you guys on october 21st so until
then uh
stay healthy stay safe
stay focused
keep having fun keep kicking ass uh
enjoy your gaming and i'll see you down
the road
this is black adam
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
now
i kneel before no one
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did you just catch a rocket
oh
[Music]
plus two three
bring it
back one two three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do what it takes
[Music]
i'm so fresh
yes
[Music]
[Music]
that was so fun to see courage and ray
and that fall guys piece and you can
play and download fall guys for free
starting june 21st across all platforms
including nintendo switch xbox pc and
playstation all right back to another
new game announcement we're going to
announce a brand new game and universe
from a new team of legendary developers
check this out
[Music]
i'll do one last scan see you soon over
okay hurry
[Music]
now we're talking
command i
may be on to something
[Music]
i have it command repeat i have it
mission
accomplished ugh
hang tight doc i've got this
[Music]
[Applause]
glad you could make it we gotta move
now
there's a storm coming
and hell's coming with it
there you have it tim congratulations
stormgate is real we have a name and
some details uh so first of all
congratulations on this announcement
we're so excited about the return of rts
brand new uh franchise what is a
stormgate though all right so stormgates
are portals that open during a massive
solar storm that unleash the infernal
host on future earth
okay uh and we saw some hints of some i
mean you know you guys coming from
blizzard and starcraft everyone wants to
know about races uh you know tell us
about the sides in this rts game yeah
we're unveiling our first two factions
today but there will be more uh so the
human resistance and we saw an
archaeologist from the human resistance
in that
intro cinematic and then also the
infernal hosts who are these demon-like
monsters who come from another world
i think one thing everyone wants to know
about especially your background
pedigree of the team of you know where
do you want to push the rts genre it's
something we've all loved for decades
but you know opportunity for a lot of
innovation um i know you're going to
show us i think some some hints of where
you're going to go image-wise with the
actual gameplay made in unreal engine
but any sense of what you want to do for
the game play in this game
absolutely i but the first thing i want
to say is we are very consciously trying
to stay true to what players already
love about rts um
where were really trying to push the
genre and be innovative first off
approachability
for one thing we're free to play
but no pay to win no nfts nothing like
that
just to
lower that barrier to entry to get
players in but we're also really trying
to be a lot more social so you'll be
able to play the campaign cooperatively
we've got three-player open-ended co-op
um and we've even got three versus three
for competitive multiplayer but of
course we've also still got one v1
competitive and as a little surprise i
think we've got some first kind of work
in progress images uh from the game
right yeah these are still very much
still uh being worked on but some shots
of uh actual assets that we're building
in unreal engine five wow well i i love
it 2023 you said for the betas people
can sign up now get ready and i'm just
so thrilled that there is a a brand new
rts franchise coming from you guys and
your background and what you did you
know blizzard and starcraft we're so
excited about this team frosh giant uh
thank you so much for giving us your
announcement today on summer game fest
thank you so much for having us here
really grateful awesome all right frost
giant stormgate keep an eye out for it
now it's time for another indie game
announcement that i'm excited to share
with you high water check this one out
[Music]
good morning high water dwellers high
water pirate radio keeping you in the
know with our flow
alphaville authorities continue to deny
false rumors that alphaville elites are
planning to evacuate to mars true or not
the one thing we can't deny is that the
world ended on a sunny day
[Music]
the wave was coming but the sky was
clear
i let it wash over
[Music]
the world
ended on a sunny day
boys and girls surfing in the bay
children climb within the park no one
suspected the coming dark
dark
what a breathtaking trailer high water
is an adventure strategy game set in a
world ravaged by extreme climate change
now speaking of the world around us the
conflict in ukraine is not far from
anyone's mind and it's impacted the
development of games including replaced
from sad cat studios a belarusian studio
with devs from belarus and ukraine the
team had long hoped to reveal a new
trailer here today but we're
understandably unable to complete it in
time guys i just want to say we're
thinking of you and all the developers
impacted by the conflict and hope to be
able to share your work at a future show
all right our next game is an official
selection of the tribeca games festival
it's american arcadia where you play
trevor whose life is being televised
with the viewing population constantly
voting you up or down when you become
unpopular you need to start running for
your life
check this out
[Music]
picture a city where technology and
science go hand in hand with fun and
entertainment
my grandfather
elijah walton had a dream to build the
city of tomorrow that dream
is now a reality and that city is
arcadia
a 43 square mile metropolis where each
and every citizen enjoys a life of
luxury and comfort
broadcast live 24 hours a day seven days
a week on every digital platform
american arcadia
control
subject on the run on camera 4025
interrupt broadcast immediately
[Music]
[Music]
listen to me we can't allow trevor hills
to escape under any circumstances
trevor
trevor can you hear me
be careful and don't make a sound
[Music]
don't
worry i'm going to get you out of there
apparently we've made it to the beach
next up is a sequel we've all been
anticipating for a long time there's
trouble in paradise and watch out you
don't want to get bitten after many
years of rumors we finally get an update
on this much anticipated sequel
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
there you have it that was goat
simulator 3 and it's coming later this
year to the epic game store
now last year marvel and 2k announced
marvel's midnight sons a tactical rpg
from firaxis games the studio behind
x-com and civilizations heroes from the
avengers and x-men cross over with
supernatural ones like blade and ghost
rider for a battle against lilith the
mother of demons today we've got a look
at some new folks set to join the battle
[Music]
this world has no hope under your watch
surrender your pain to me
and i will make you home once more
mother won't hurt you
typical parker luck
i'm gonna need some backup
[Music]
[Music]
master of puppies
is
[Music]
that used to always work well it did
that one time
that was midnight suns and now we're
moving on to the wonderful world of
cuphead the delicious last course and
can you believe it we're only a couple
weeks away from playing the delicious
last course dlc you see how they did
that for cuphead joining me now is maya
maldenhauer from studio mdhr so first of
all maya it's really coming it's really
coming june 30th on all major platforms
we are thrilled well i'm so thrilled too
that uh i think all the fans can't
believe that this is here and i've been
lucky enough to play this actually on my
steam deck uh last weekend you guys gave
me a copy this
i can't people are not gonna be ready
for how amazing this looks and the
backgrounds and what you guys have done
i feel like you've you've amped up
obviously the gameplay it's difficult as
we would expect but the visual look you
guys have taken it even to the next
level so i think was possible yeah we
absolutely did i couldn't pinpoint one
thing that we're proud of in this
because we really honed our craft took
everything to the next level from
animation the backgrounds the music
gameplay design um and of course a new
playable character miss chalice i'm very
proud of her
chalice is fun to play as and even
though this is a dlc it feels like it's
its own game inside of cuphead in many
ways it is it is definitely yeah you
just get on the island and there you are
off to this new uh new territory which
is yeah it's our biggest island yet
super-sized bosses lots of secrets to
discover um don't let any rock go
unturned yes and lots of challenge ahead
well i know you brought i know you want
you don't want people to necessarily
have too much spoiled about the game but
you brought a little something a little
something yeah it's a brand new gameplay
footage of one of our new bosses
mortimer freeze it takes place in an icy
arena
and feature some of my personal favorite
attacks and transformations we hope
everyone enjoys it all right let's check
it out cuphead the delicious last course
next wild
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look
[Music]
now if you want even more cuphead and
who doesn't tomorrow we will show you an
exclusive look at season two of the
cuphead show when i co-host netflix's
geek tweak which will include new show
and game announcements it streams at 10
a.m pacific 1 p.m eastern
and that's not all there's more summer
game fest all weekend long coming up
next is the day of the devs indie
showcase with i am 8 bit and double fine
then devolver's marketing countdown to
marketing tomorrow after geeked week
there is the epic game store showcase at
11am pacific 2pm eastern with news on
rocket league and the tribeca games
showcase and sunday don't miss the xbox
and bethesda game showcase with a look
at the future of xbox and game pass
now we have some exciting news for
nintendo switch and pc fans about neon
white a game where you play an assassin
from hell who slays demons for the
chance to ascend to heaven
[Music]
we're called neons
sinners plucked from hell to do god's
dirty work
but i'm finding it hard to believe we're
in heaven
ten days here new day you mission from
all mikey
you think you can win me over by
showering me with gifts uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we've shown you lots of games today made
by huge teams now it's time for a game
made by a single father in poland
over the past year he's brought on some
help to bring his vision for a
fast-paced action game midnight fight
express to life let's take a look
[Music]
you know the saying
get knocked down get up again that whole
spiel
well it's time partner
time to rise up together
[Music]
it's happening the big guy's actually
going through with it
while i side of the side seeing lives as
dollar signs
have a stink of corruption all over me
you know who put it there
not him
me
well i ain't wearing it anymore and
neither are you
tonight we wash this whole damn city
down
such a cool game i'm happy to announce
that a pc demo of this game is going
live right now on steam and will be part
of the steam next fest next week i
really want more playable games to get
in the hands of you guys at home and
that's one of them check it out all
right joining me now is megan from
digital extremes to talk all things
warframe megan how you doing i'm so good
my fellow canadians i know we got like
we just happen to always have these
canadian teams on the show i don't know
how that works out right okay we do well
we have a great connection we've also
done a lot with warframe over the years
and i know right now anyone watching on
twitch for more than 30 minutes this
show is going to get a special twitch
drop right that's right i already have
seen people getting it so it's very
exciting she's right there loud and
proud protea 30 minutes for watching
thank you for letting us kind of take
over your special events category but
she is there and she is for you if you
are properly linked up no warframe you
know as i said we've done a lot over the
years you guys have done incredible
things with the game and i know you have
tennocon coming up in july which is your
big kind of event of the year to reveal
what's next what what can you tell us
well i can't tell too much but yeah july
16 2022 it's a digital event again this
year today actually we just launched the
digital items for it so you can get some
in-game goodies some really cool
cosmetics some merch all that really
great stuff went live today but of
course the reason i'm here
is to you know kind of debut we have our
tenno live during tennocon which is our
big reveal of the night and we usually
do a little bit of a game play a little
bit of a demo and i think a lot of
people can suspect what it might be but
i'm here to kind of confirm what it is
that tunnel live is going to show and
what is that
can i say it yes i think you can okay
you're going to get your first look at
the diviri paradox finally finally i
know i know it's been a couple of years
but de vere paradox is going to be what
tenno live is all about and i'm so happy
the team worked really hard on the
teaser you're about to see for it and
i'm just really proud and excited to
show it awesome well thanks so much for
being here on summer game fest let's
take a look at that right now
[Music]
my child
my friend
what was done is done
[Music]
new dangers
new choices await us now
[Applause]
[Music]
for now
dream of who we were
and of who we have become
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next it's time for a new look at hong
kai star rail an upcoming open world
space rpg yeah a lot of space today from
gentian impact studio hoya verse across
mobile and pc this studio continues to
deliver and this new trailer reveals for
the very first time a new and exotic
realm players will be able to explore
[Music]
listen
you are in a daze right now
you don't know who you are
why you're here
none of that matters
in the near future
you will encounter many perils
you will meet companions who treat you
like family
and embark on unimaginable adventures
remember what you feel in this moment
as long as you know in your heart where
you're heading
you will arrive at the end of the story
that's the you i like
[Music]
i have wine to soothe the souls of
honored guests
[Music]
and that's not all from hoyoverse today
i'm excited to introduce you to zenless
zone zero their next major new ip it's a
futuristic urban action game i have to
say i'm blown away by what i've seen so
far it was announced a couple weeks ago
and it has the detail of gentian impact
with a fast-paced action style here is
the world premiere of a brand new look
at zenless's notable characters armed
enemies and world of danger
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
all right
all right
so
one of my favorite reveals last year was
tmnt shredders revenge which reminds us
all of the turtles arcade games back in
the day well it's nearing the end of
development and the team wanted to use
sgf as a way to reveal one exciting
aspect of the game they've been keeping
under wraps until now
[Music]
patrick
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[ __ ]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
how far will you push humankind
[Music]
[Music]
humankind allows you to shape your
civilization by combining a multitude of
historical civilizations from the
ancient to the modern era
one piece is celebrating its 25th
anniversary this year and bandai namco
is bringing the mega popular franchise
back to video games with one piece
odyssey monkey to luffy and his crew of
pirates are off on their next adventure
this trailer reveals the setting a
mysterious island where luffy and his
straw hat crew become marooned in this
exciting upcoming jrpg
[Music]
the straw hat pirates journey along the
grand line
foreign
is
[Music]
oh
come
on filled with new encounters
and hidden mysteries
[Music]
unravel the adventure that awaits
in an odyssey beyond imagination
one
odyssey
this august soul hackers 2 from atlas
launches and we've got your first listen
to the english voice cast with this
quick new look
[Music]
ringo
[Music]
take my hand
[Music]
[Music]
so that's our mission then save the
world
with so many new games featured across
sgf events you might be wondering how to
plan for your summer gaming dreams nerd
wallet can help you find the smartest
credit card to reward your gaming
purchases at nerdwallet.com
the epic mega sale is going on right now
save up to 75 off top pc titles with an
additional 25 off eligible products and
it wouldn't be the mega sale without the
free games vault featuring man eater be
sure to claim your copy before the sale
ends on june 16th tune in to the epic
game store twitch channel for our summer
showcase on june 10th at 2 p.m eastern
11 a.m pacific we're taking a look at
new announcements and updates from pc
titles heading to the store
this year and beyond
[Applause]
you nuts
[Music]
bye
hello
[Music]
you're gonna get hit with the unexpected
in mario striker's battle league in this
no-holds-barred soccer-ish sport chaos
reigns supreme so prepare to do whatever
it takes to claim victory so much fun it
hurts
mario striker's battle league only on
nintendo switch game rated everyone 10
and up
[Music]
hi my name is carl and i'm a developer
and metal hell singer you know how in
some games with the music is really good
you feel compelled to move and shoot to
the beat but what if you had to in metal
the better you are at slaying to the
beat the more intense everything gets
and we have vocal performances from
legendary artists like serge thank you
from system of a down so while head
banging isn't mandatory we do recommend
it our demo is live now on steam xbox
and playstation platforms so go check it
out and slay to the beat
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that one was metal hellsinger coming
later this year from funcom a rhythm
shooter with metal music and right now
as i mentioned a demo has launched on pc
xbox and playstation for you to play for
free
next up a new game launches tomorrow the
quarry from supermassive games this
spiritual successor to until dawn stars
david arquette and an all-star cast
that's getting great reviews and this is
one of those binge-worthy teen horror
entertainment experiences where your
every choice shapes your story and
determines who lives and who dies at a
camp in upstate new york here's the
first look at the launch trailer
family is the most important thing in
the world
but if your whole family
you know like
every last one of them decided to jump
down the bottom of a well they're all
just
hanging on the end of a rope
how can one person be expected to pull
them all back out you can't
[Music]
so you pull on that rope and you're just
gonna fall right down at the bottom of
the well with the rest of them
and what's the point of that
what
there is a lot more to this than you
realize
like what
kidnapping murder cover-ups i think the
whole packet family is in on it
you have no idea what's going on here
got a goddamn clue
all right let's do this
[Music]
who should i call 911. you mean 9-1-1
who says 91-1
good-bye cool world
okay get out
i'm gonna enjoy watching you die
this isn't a ghost story it's a creature
feature it's really happening and you're
all in it this is going to get a little
messy
[Music]
them's the rules you noob
back at the game awards we were proud to
reveal nightingale a shared world
survival crafting game from inflection
games up in canada now it's time to give
you a brand new look and deeper look at
the game including its innovative realm
card system that lets you impact things
like the weather pattern resources and
challenges in its procedural realms here
is your exclusive new look
[Music]
you're alone in the realms i'm afraid
the portals are a mess
not even sure if nightingale made it
given how fragile you humans are
i'd say that staying fed dry and rested
should be your priority
if the portal arch is inactive you'll
need to make round cards from rare
resources
once you have realm cards you can
activate the portal
beware
vowel things lurk in the interim void
waiting to get in
be ready with your axe pick
[Music]
[Music]
if these shadows have offended
think but this
and all is mended
the saints are marching in on august
23rd with the reboot of saints row that
we revealed last year at gamescom and
today we're happy to announce the launch
of the boss factory demo across pcm
console which lets you design and set up
your character and since it's saints row
you guys are going to have a lot of fun
with this one check it out
[Music]
you gotta do something to capture
people's attention so what do we build
next
[Music]
we are so good at this
[Music]
dinner and a show baby
cause i got one thing
[Music]
[Music]
next we've got an exclusive first look
at extended game play of warhammer 40k
darktide fat sharks follow up to the
critically acclaimed vermintide series
dark tide promises intense four-player
co-op action and terrifying enemy hordes
to team up against and it's our out on
september 13th for pc on steam and
exclusively on console on xbox
[Music]
manufacturer
1736 is heading towards your power
system's failure thanks to a bit of
heretic sabotage
so you're gonna restore the colon and
hopefully save the day
[Music]
again
access the operations array and use the
cryonic rods to flush the system
preferably before something explodes
head on through the ventilation tunnels
and look for an access point
this way move it
[Applause]
prime the rods
that's the first part done
get to the base of the matrix bar and
put those cryonic rods to work
look for a way out
[Music]
bluebird team is known for psychological
horror games like blair witch and the
medium today they are ready to reveal
their latest creation made completely in
unreal engine 5 for a visceral horror
experience it's a return to the world of
layers of fears get a dose
of this
[Music]
someone once said insanity runs in our
family
let it run
they say it's a tale of sadness and
guilt
of an artist trapped in place beyond
redemption
and it is mine
to tell
now i see it
all this misery
all this suffering
there was no other way
you really
shouldn't
have
an empty shell
cannot live forever
[Music]
now
i break free
this october gotham nights arrives
batman is dead and it's up to the batman
family batgirl nightwing red hood and
robin to protect gotham to give us an
exclusive new look let's head to
montreal to hear from executive producer
fleur marty
[Music]
hello and warm welcome from wb games
montreal i'm fla marti i'm the executive
producer on gotham knights
today we are thrilled to share more with
you on one of our beloved nights
nightwing
this showcase is the first in our
character series and we're really
looking forward to share more with you
as we continue working towards our
launch on october 25th
so i hope you enjoyed the show and stay
tuned
[Music]
i had nothing
and then this city became my home
its people became my family
gotham gave me everything
it deserves to feel safe
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
no matter how hard we try
there's always more to do
and now
it's up to me
i got this bruce
that was gotham knights and now we
welcome oh look who it is neil druckmann
from naughty dog
co-president of naughty dog uh great to
have you with us neil it's been a uh an
eventful day on the internet for naughty
dog fans and uh i think we jinxed
ourselves we were joking about last
night like watch the assets will leak
and yes lo and behold that's what
happened well the good news is there's
some stuff that hasn't leaked that we
have lots to share with people about uh
all things at naughty dog but first of
all it is a you know it's a big month
actually for lastos fans because uh last
of us one and two both launched in june
and it's nearing its two-year
anniversary for the last of us uh part
two which is hard to hard to believe
yeah it's crazy uh um you know nine
years for last of us one two years for
less was part two and we still hear from
fans they're still sending us letters
and art and these characters in this
journey in this world means so much to
them
um
and it's it's just been kind of amazing
like last week's part two early this
year passed a pretty big milestone it
sold over 10 million units and that kind
of support that kind of success we're so
grateful to our fans it has allowed us
to grow as a studio and now we can take
on multiple projects more than we've
ever had at the same time
multiple projects okay very interesting
so uh what can last us last of us fans
expect in the future from you thank you
for asking jeff uh so one of the things
we've mentioned a while back is what
started out as a multiplayer mode has
evolved due to the team's ambition they
really wanted to do something beyond
what we've ever done before naughty dog
and we felt the way to do it justice is
to make it a standalone title and over
the they've been working on it for the
past two years ambition has grown and
we're not quite ready to fully unveil it
but we're ready to lift the current a
little bit and just give you like an
update of where we're at
okay well uh what can you tell us about
this new standalone multiplayer game
yeah so uh we have a concept art that we
want to show um
uh but what i can tell you oh
is that this game is big okay um it's as
big as any of our single-player games
that we've done and in some ways bigger
it's got a story um the way we're
telling that story is very unique to
this game
it's got a brand new cast of characters
it takes place at another place another
part of the united states like a city
might somewhat familiar some people i'm
sure our fans have already figured it
out um
uh and it's it's it's really cool and
it's being headed by vinith agarwal um
anthony newman and uh joe pandnaty all
veterans of uncharted and last of us and
you're gonna see a lot more of this game
come next year
next year so i wait till next year to
hear more about that one okay well very
exciting that uh this has evolved and i
mean that concept art looks incredible i
can't wait to see naughty dog
storytelling fused with multiplayer live
game uh it's it's something special we
can't wait to show it either okay well
um that's not all we also have something
that i've been reading about on the
internet every day it feels like up in
calgary they're filming the last of us
show for hbo right
yeah so uh for the past year um you know
we've teamed up with craig mason of
chernobyl fame and hbo to adapt the last
of us into a tv uh tv show um they've
been filming and uh
it's pretty incredible the stuff i'm
getting back when we're looking at back
at naughty dog we can't help but feel
emotional because not only is it so good
and the quality is so high it's so
authentic to what we've made in the game
um and
uh i i just can't i couldn't be proud of
like again craig and that whole crew and
everybody that's up there uh and they're
actually their last day of filming is
tomorrow so the entire series last day
of filming they are filming us tomorrow
craig is up there right now kind of
wrapping it all up uh so it's it's
pretty close it's closer than you might
think and you actually got to direct one
of the episodes
yes uh i think that really speaks to the
kind of collaboration and trust that
exists between naughty dog and hbo they
invited me to direct one of the episodes
um i think we have an image from the
episode actually directed ooh
we could first look let's take
so you can see uh this is a certain
museum that players might know from the
game um and i really have to talk about
pedro pascal and bella ramsey and not
only directing them but seeing them do
all the other episodes they've thrown
themselves at these roles um for a whole
year
watching the nuance that they bring to
these characters their relationship on
and off camera i couldn't help but think
about troy baker and ashley johnson it
felt so similar to the chemistry those
two actors had when we made the game um
and it really feels like this is going
to be
something special and i will say this
will be the most authentic video game
adaptation yet well i mean that first
image that they put out it just i mean
it feels like the video game everything
that i've seen both public and other
stuff makes it feel sort of super
legitimate you said and that's awesome
to see uh joel and ellie from from the
front side now for the first time um so
we'll see more of that next year that's
coming as well right serious uh you'll
hear about it very soon that's okay i'll
say right now all right well last of us
hbo very very exciting uh and i hear you
actually have a couple actors from the
show who are gonna join us you happen to
have a couple actors here that are part
of the show we should bring them up okay
come on up
oh what's up guys oh hello
surprise troye's back again hello hello
good to see you good to see you uh i'm a
little confused though i thought maybe
pedro bella but troy ashley out here
from the game right so uh when craig and
i started working on the show almost one
of our very first meetings we said troy
and ashley have to be a part of it um
and we're such fans of like the talent
and the help like helping us create joel
and ellie um we felt like it was so
important that they become part of the
show and it wasn't it's it has to be
more than just like kind of like a wink
to the camera and like a cameo yeah
these are real roles that we're keeping
under wraps for now
uh but man i was i'm bummed that i
couldn't be there with you guys when you
filmed your stuff there's been so much
stuff so like so good on the internet
there's so much like talk about what's
being filmed and i think that's you guys
have kept a complete secret that you so
you were up there and you filmed your
roles by now obviously well keeping
secrets with this franchise is kind of
old hat like we've had for today
except for the date
uh it was it was one of the hardest
things for us to do is to let not let
people know that because we're so proud
of it and the work that we did we worked
hard the crew i have to say
when i walked out on set
um
to be met with literally every person
that i met on that crew
is such a fan of this game and they all
knew what it was that they were working
on and committed to working on this
project because of their fan and their
love for the for the game uh was one of
the greatest it was like i was coming
home
to friends
yeah i i the attention to detail
the crew was amazing bella and pedro are
man
i
they're so perfect and it it we've been
trying to sort of describe that feeling
of sort of seeing them in person
it's it's like
it's like the characters coming to life
but it
it's so much more than that i feel like
i can't fully explain it but i am
so excited to be a part of it and just
i can't wait to see it i think it is
going to be
so good it's it's i love the story i
love just
i'm so excited about the series and the
fact that you guys are gonna be in it
and undisclosed roles i'm so fascinated
how it's gonna sort of
bob and weaving and you know are these
characters we know from the game that
they're playing new characters can you
tell us anything
yes
i can tell you so sneaky all right well
we're so excited maybe it's already on
twitter
hey all right well
let's talk about what was on twitter
earlier uh today lots of talk about uh
the idea or really what's happening is
it looks like you guys are remaking the
original game and this is like a
ground-up remake is that right that's
right uh we wanted to give people the
definitive version of the the first game
that wasn't encumbered by any technology
uh wanted to find a way to get even
closer to our original vision and we're
able to do it on the ps5 and pc and
instead of talk about it let's look at
it all right let's take a look at the
last of us part one
so why'd you leave boston
i've been on quite the adventure little
brother
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl
he's got everything to do with that
little girl
[Music]
you know
i've never been this close
to the outside
so is that everything you hoped for
can't be any worse out there
can it
[Applause]
once upon a time i had somebody that i
cared about
and in this world that's good for one
thing
get you killed
i can take care of myself how many close
calls have we had
i get in trouble down there you make
every shot
count
i got this
hope you know how to use that thing
i've had some practice
truly one of my favorite games of the
past decade guys what's your reaction to
that yeah we haven't seen that yet yeah
you're watching it in real time
uh
it's because you did these before i mean
these performances you did a decade ago
yeah you didn't go back in i mean you
used the original performances yeah
actually we came up with a process where
we could take the original
uh animation that we did for the faces
and kind of like retargeted on these new
rigs that have a lot more fidelity and
then the animators went back and forth
side by sides here just how much it has
changed that you went and you redid the
models and we built everything
everything was rebuilt from the ground
up same art director re-art directed the
whole thing from the ground up
but the the great thing about these
faces is that um they're closer to their
original performance all the animators
went and studied those videos and got it
closer to what you did on set than we
could have achieved before
um and that's just like one of the
things and we could talk about like this
brand new ai like all the combat is
redone um
just uh the fidelity of everything 60
frames per second all the stuff you're
getting on the ps5 again we wanted to
give knowing because of the show because
this they're all all new players for ps5
and pc yeah we wanted them to have the
definitive version of the last of us
amazing well now you guys get to replay
i mean when was the last time you guys
played the game
i i actually played it again just to
refresh my memory before working on the
show
um
i was a just a glutton for punishment
and i went straight from playing uh
never playing straight into part two
um and so the last time i played
literally would have been two years ago
since we're celebrating the anniversary
of part two coming out so i mean it
looks like i'm definitely going to be up
for another playthrough
yeah i can't wait to go back because i
can't you guys do such an amazing job on
that original game and it's it's really
when you play it when you see it in
motion it's really night and day from
what it used to be i imagine that you
know the think of the last of us two
combat but kind of that back in the last
of us once it's the whole like all the
new animation system the new ai system
everything we've learned on like
untreaded four last of us two we applied
to this again to give that definitive
version just to give a quick shout out
uh this project is headed up by matthew
gallant and shauna skye
uh and you'll hear a lot more about and
see a lot more about over the coming
weeks leading up to the release
september 2nd on ps5
all right well surely they're after on
pc we will look forward to not you neil
you've talked a lot about
games directed by other people what are
you directing you still making games
still making games i haven't given up my
day job uh
it's a little early to talk about it
maybe if someone in place and wants to
leak it then we can talk about it now uh
otherwise uh we'll say you do have a new
project do have a new project
but we'll save it for another summer
game fest okay
okay well we'll see we'll try and save
it all right troy ashley neal thank you
so much for dropping by summer game fest
and i am so excited that the last of us
is returning as you said in september so
thanks guys appreciate it thanks jeff
awesome
all right well that is gonna do it
thanks to naughty dog and playstation
for that very special uh look at the
last of us and the entire franchise and
where things are going um very very
excited about that all right summer game
fest continues over the next few days
coming up right now on this dairy stream
is day of the des with i am 8bit and
double fine including an exclusive new
look at the planet atlanta and then the
devolver digital showcase tomorrow we've
got netflix geeked week which i'll be
co-hosting and the tribeca game showcase
streaming along with the epic game store
showcase and then finally sunday it's
the xbox and bethesda game showcase you
can stream them all at
summergamefest.com as for me i'll see
you again in august when we are back
live in cologne germany for gamescom
opening night live on august 23rd and
then the game awards will return in
december live from the microsoft theater
in los angeles and finally i'm excited
to share that summer game fest will
return in june 2023 as a digital and
in-person event to bring the gaming
community together thanks for being a
part of summer game fast and remember
there are more events and announcements
to come we'll see you soon
[Music]
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday day of the dead
what you don't know what day of the devs
is day of the devs is the greatest and
definitely the oldest independent games
festival that exists it was started over
10 years ago by double fine productions
and i made it to celebrate uh the best
independent games out there and bring
them to you the fans we want to bring
developers and players together to get
together play games and have a great
time it used to be a physical event only
in san francisco but now it has gone
digital so the whole world can enjoy it
and we're really excited this year to be
part of uh summer game fest uh so sit
back relax put on your party hats
this thing i'm supposed to put this on
that's right everybody
put on your party hats
everybody
everybody
that's right that looks good now we're
cooking
put on your party hat
and enjoy day of the deaths
[Music]
we got a new one today this is from a
good friend michael frey and rafael
munoz previously michael made a game
called kids with playables that we
published at double fine presents and
this is his new one it's about the
limited time we have on earth told
through the life of a fly this is called
time flies
[Music]
hello everyone
my name is michael
you might know my work from a game
called plug and play
a co-founded
company called playables where we made
a game called kids
but today we're going to talk about this
guy
in my upcoming project
that is a collaboration with rafael
munoz who is the principal programmer on
the game the project we're collaborating
on is called time flies
[Music]
time flies is about our limited time in
this world in switzerland where i'm
right now we have a life expectancy of
maybe 84 years in the us it's about 77
years
so you have a little bit less time to
achieve the things you want in your life
[Music]
come on
[Music]
in time flies the things you can achieve
are nicely prepared on a bucket list
this is a very small part of that bucket
list
so these are the things you can do in
the world
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the game is coming to playstation
nintendo switch
pc and mac
sometime next year
please visit
timeflies.bus
where you can
sign up for the newsletter
so you get updated when it's out
or you find a link to the steam page
where you can wishlist again thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
our next game is planet of lana the
debut title from sweden based wishfully
studios and published by thunderful
publishing the gameplay is reminiscent
of dark side scrollers like inside and
little nightmares but the vibes could
not be more different
who are these enigmatic enemies
what do they want with lana's sister and
her world and what other secrets are
there to uncover in this beautiful
boundless environment
hello my name is adam juanyus and i'm
the creative director at wishfully
we're a small indie game studio in
sweden making planet
in our game you play a young girl called
lana who is forced out on a mission to
save her sister that has been taken away
by an invading robot army
on in the game lana meets the mystical
creature maui
you quickly develop a strong bond and
friendship to maui and she proves to be
both intelligent and loyal
[Music]
being her own personality
mummy also has things that she's afraid
of
[Music]
but being small and agile also has its
advantages for example being able to
reach places that you can't
[Music]
she also has this special ability she
can use to control some of the strange
creatures of this planet
together you have to make it through
both the harsh and beautiful
environments of noble
past dangerous robots
through deep and cold caves
unravelling long forgotten mysteries
that all lead to your destined future
[Music]
planet of lana is really a labor of love
and we're very excited here at wishfully
to bring you what we believe is a truly
unique adventure and beyond the
companion-based puzzle solving and
hand-painted art style you will
experience an engaging story with twists
and turns that hopefully will stay with
you long after the credits have rolled
planet of lana is coming to xbox and pc
this year and you can wish list right
now at steam or sign up at our
newsletter at planet oflana.com
this next title from two star games is
quite literally an on the rails shooter
you and your little yellow train with
its mounted machine gun and exquisite
collection of bobble heads face off
against a demonic clown-faced train who
is hell-bent on devouring human flesh
this is choo choo charles
hey i'm gavin i'm the solo developer
behind two star games and i'm currently
making choo choo charles
[Music]
it's an open world horror game where you
navigate an island in an old
train upgrade over time and then use it
to fight an evil spider train named
charles
if you pump enough lead into his face
i'll probably encourage him to run off
and find something else
you have one goal above all else and
that's to summon charles to a 1v1 and
fight him to the death
to do that you'll need to explore the
open world looting abandoned areas and
completing missions for the locals to
gain powerful new weapons and scraps
that you can use to upgrade your trains
speed armor
out there because it might be unwise to
wander too far from your train
if you do encounter charles while you're
roaming around it doesn't matter what
you do now because you have truly
angered the beast and you'll either
escape with your life or see it flash
before your eyes
sounds like something for you be sure to
follow and wish list choo choo charles
on steam i'd greatly appreciate it
really does mean a lot
we've got a special one for you it's
very personal and near and dear to i
make it because it's a i ima presents
published title it's called escape
academy and think of it like hogwarts
but for escape rooms it's from developer
coin crew games and they hail from the
arcade amusement space they've designed
escape rooms in real life better they
talk about their game than me here they
are
hey i'm mike
i'm wyatt and i'm michelle the art
director
wait am i supposed to say i'm the
hey i'm mike i'm wyatt we're the
founders and i'm michelle the art
director oh okay this is the i hate that
all right once once more with healing
hey i'm mike
i'm wyatt and i'm michelle and we're
coinker games
[Music]
when coin crew games was founded uh we
were actually building real world escape
rooms and arcade machines but when the
pandemic hit we needed to pivot so we
decided to take those learnings building
real world escape rooms and transpose
them into a digital format unless escape
academy was born
[Music]
good luck trying to hack me without
sufficient power probability of your
expulsion i escape academy is an escape
room adventure game that you can play
either single player or co-op
you play as a student at this titular
mysterious escape academy where you get
to master the art of puzzle solving and
train to become the ultimate escapist
what are you waiting for a room full of
gas is no place to relax
we're all fans of escape rooms so when
we couldn't find a digital authentic
escape room experience we decided to
make one ourselves
walls are often misleading at the
academy
escape academy isn't just a puzzle game
it's an escape room game and it brings
that play pattern home we have a huge
amount of puzzles in this game and they
never repeat and in addition to that you
can solve every puzzle using just your
mind no dexterity required although you
may want to bring a paper and pencil
[Music]
the academic theming gave us the
leverage to create a wide variety of
rooms that support the narrative and put
players in situations they would never
find themselves in in real life escape
rooms
when we were designing the game it was
really helpful to have
the experience of both playing a lot of
escape rooms and designing real world
escape rooms as sort of a design anchor
to buoy us to
[Music]
i did not anticipate the rodent
assisting you
bad tumeric
sadly that rat will be no help in
bypassing my lasers we really took our
time to create an eclectic cast of
students and faculty members that helped
guide you throughout the academic
journey of escape academy
[Music]
building on the lessons that you get in
each room and raising mistakes
throughout your journey at the academy
was definitely a design pillar we wanted
to make sure it came through in the
final game
i am not here so well
analysis i have succumbed to
disco fever
escape academy is coming to xbox
playstation and pc on july 14 and will
be available day one on xbox game pass
and you can wishlist us today on steam
we'll see you at the academy thanks
this game's for all those fans of
organization out there all those
organizers it's from a studio called max
inferno and it's a game about getting
things lined up just right
it's called a little to the left
[Music]
hi i'm annie hi and i'm lucas and we are
max inferno
yep we're really excited to share with
you today a cozy puzzle game that we've
been working on called a little to the
left
[Music]
a little to the left is a game where you
sort stack and tidy up the house
in each level puzzles are hidden among
regular household objects
and you solve them by arranging items in
a very particular way
[Music]
many of the levels have multiple
solutions
it's all about observation
and imagining the different structures
that could be at play
the game takes inspiration from our own
home
[Music]
and some of our own little tendencies
another big source of inspiration for
the game is our cat rookie
who should be around here somewhere
[Music]
occasionally this cat will show up on
the periphery of your gameplay
and undo your tidy work
just to shake things up a little bit
the game starts off pretty simple
but as you progress the logic behind the
puzzles becomes a little more
surreal
[Laughter]
[Music]
there is a lot to tidy up in a little to
the left
actually every day brings something new
[Music]
with the daily tidy delivery
you get even more out of our favorite
puzzles
and you earn fun badges too
[Music]
well thanks for stopping by
we hope you enjoy a little to the left
when it releases later this year
see you later bye
[Music]
i've been excited about this one ever
since it was announced ages ago it's
from developer gummy cat it's called
bear and breakfast and the title says it
all you're a bear you run in bed and
breakfast in the woods and it's really
freaking fun we're debuting a brand new
animated trailer a bunch of gameplay
you've never seen and finally announcing
a release date
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm iona and i'm radish we're from gummy
cat in romania today we're showing you
our first game called bear and breakfast
it's a laid back management adventure
game where you build and run a bmb in
the woods but you're a bear
[Music]
in bear and breakfast you play as hank
a young curious bear from silver valley
who lives in a small home with his mom
and two best friends
[Music]
we grew up on management sims
games like theme hospital were big
inspirations for us but we also wanted
to make a game that tells a story
alongside the usual management stuff
[Music]
so it turns out that humans are coming
back for some reason and they need a
place to stay there's old rundown
buildings all over the place and you're
just the bear for the job
[Music]
the game follows a linear story that you
advance by solving quests
a lot of them involve finding materials
building rooms crafting furniture and
decorating stuff
[Music]
the actual furniture you do make awards
different kinds of points for instance
beds give comfort showers give hygiene
that type of thing
you have to make sure that your room
scores are high enough to satisfy
whatever your guests are asking for
each type of score comes with its own
challenges for example later on you'll
need to cook food for your guests
through a mini game
there's a lot more to bearing breakfast
but you can play at your own pace since
the game won't rush you
[Music]
oh and there's definitely no creepy
subplot hidden somewhere in the forest
[Music]
we're very excited to be part of day of
the devs this year and we can't wait to
introduce you all to hank and his
friends when baron breakfast launches
later this summer
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so i don't want to say a lot about this
next one uh it's full of secrets and
puzzles and mystery that are best
discovered on your own it's a beautiful
game from a studio called shared memory
it's a
pixel art metroidvania full of
interesting creatures it's called animal
well
hi i'm billy basso today i'm going to be
showing you a game i've been working on
called animal well
[Music]
[Laughter]
in animal well you explore a surreal
and sometimes dangerous pixelart
labyrinth
that is filled with secrets
as you explore you'll encounter
various creatures but it's not always
clear if they're friendly or not so
it's best to
proceed with some amount of caution
[Music]
[Music]
throughout the game you're going to find
various items that will
give you new abilities and help you
solve some puzzles
[Music]
every item in the game has multiple uses
but you're gonna have to experiment if
you want to figure out what they all are
huh
[Music]
animal well is a pixlr game
that's not just a pander to nostalgia
instead i'm viewing as a technical
opportunity a 4k tv screen has 144
times as many pixels but
that means i have 144 times as much
processing power to apply to each pixel
throughout the game you'll see a lot of
things like fluid sims or
dynamic lighting effects that haven't
really been used in a pixlr game before
[Music]
designing animal law is a layered
experience so what that means is
the base layer is something the average
person can play through and enjoy to
completion
but then there's a second layer which
for most games you would consider this
part like 100 in the game
there are lots of hidden items
in nooks and crannies throughout the
world
they're not obvious and they you might
need some help to find these
the third layer has puzzles that don't
really present themselves as puzzles
they might go unnoticed for years
potentially or they might require some
community collaboration to solve
also there's a
there's a puzzle in this video
that may require some community
collaboration to understand but
the first 10 people to
figure it out we'll get a free copy of
the game at launch
and then while you're doing that you can
maybe wish list it
[Music]
but yeah thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
next up is nyad a colorful exploration
game where you play as a water nymph
traversing a zen and peaceful world this
game comes to us from high warp a solo
developer from spain
hi i'm really happy to be part of the
10th anniversary of the other days at
this exciting summerfest video i'm
melvin from highward a solid devinder
studio from spain working on bringing to
life very unique personal gains
i would like to say we do apprehend a
relaxing and qualified exploitation and
dental overflowing by a river
i put all my love creating every part of
this game so please enjoy
[Music]
the journey starts with the birth of a
lady water lymph at the spring of the
river nya will grow up a matter of time
in vitality from floating leaves and
flowers
learning to swim like a dark dive like a
fish
that's like a frog
finding other adorable friends like
butterflies rabbits snakes turtles
coconut rice and much more
help them to find their way avoiding
obstacles and dangers using your skills
julian mers throw a lot of beautiful
places like a deep forest
a dark cave
a joyful creek
and more
water symbolizing life is that pure and
fresh
and lit a little it will be fading into
that
you can seem to regenerate the natural
making sprout flowers in the path
and you must do your best because the
humans
are controlling this river goal
humans create their own fake rivers like
these nice roads with strange smoke
creatures
you are the guardian of this river and
that seems to be a difficult task but
don't be afraid because a tiny cloud
will take care of you from the sky
the beautiful hair of nayyad is like its
hospitality you can make it grow up
under the sunrise change its color even
tie small flowers on it
creating ayat i focused on a wholesome
experience
enjoy it at your own pace exploring and
flowing they are available for pc and
consoles by the end of this year
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
if you ever find yourself longing for
the good old days then why not take a
trip back to the stone age in this
cooperative life and farming simulation
game from soderden and cryptico hunt and
gather to care for your settlement
explore the ancient world around you and
best of all become a friend to the
mammoths this is roots of pacha
hi i'm timo co-founder of soda then
along with my brother
hi i'm karen the narrative designer
we're based in san diego with the rest
of the team in argentina hola todos i am
dancer the main artist and i'm johnny
timo's brother we are the team
developing roots of pacha a farming
scene set in the stone age where you
help your clan develop the ideas that
shape humanity
[Music]
in a time when there weren't stores to
buy seeds or anything else you'll build
your village from the ground up
[Music]
instead of using money you'll transform
the world around you by contributing and
working with your clan
starting small you'll explore the
regions of this new land discovering
plants and resources along the way
[Music]
many of the ideas you developed were the
cornerstones of early civilizations like
farming domesticating animals and the
creation of tools that are now common
ideas will build on one another and
after a while you'll find your community
transformed
[Music]
[Music]
you'll venture into the caves to meet
the spiritual world to try and explain
who you are and why you're here
the game's stoneage setting was inspired
by the book the clan of the cave bear
rootsapacha is set in simpler times but
society is still complex
for example finding something to eat
went from satisfying a basic need to
making a dish and creating a reason to
gather
[Music]
as you discover ways to make life easier
you'll find time to experience all the
fun pacha's world has to offer
[Music]
you'll get to know your clan meet others
living around you and maybe even find
that special someone
our love of farming sims started with
the first harvest moons and sardi valley
took it to the next level
with roots of pacha we want to make our
own unique contribution to the genre
we're working on this project with all
of our hearts we're super excited for
you to play the final version in the
meantime we have a brand new demo that
just went live today thanks for having
us
[Music]
and now i am very pleased to present a
world premiere from our friends at us
two games the folks who brought you
monument valley alba and a bunch of
other really really cool games
here it is
[Music]
at those two games we really try and
take what's meaningful and great about
games and deliver that to everybody so
with monument valley we make people care
about a character for the first time if
they've never really engaged with games
very much and with alba wildlife
adventure we took open world games and
packaged that into a kind of theme about
saving an island that more people are
going to want to engage with than just
the hardcore and with this game what we
really want to do is take these genres
that we really love like roguelike games
and turn-based tactics add a little bit
of sports game in there as well and
themes about dreams and conflicting
fears and really package that together
into something that feels really unique
in the game you play the role of dester
he's a young person in their early 20s
he's coming home for the first time
having not left home in their the very
best way their relationship with their
mother and their family and their
friends there's a few of them that were
a little bit broken and they were broken
because they didn't really have the
words to say and their father who used
to be a big part of their life
unfortunately passes away and they don't
have those tools and that person to lean
on to bridge that gap
so they manage to go home they find this
old ball they use to play with their dad
and when they try and fall asleep with
it they find themselves in a world
between worlds neither asleep nor awake
and when they're in this they can
explore these moments these memories and
solve these creative problems through a
through a ball game and when they do
that they find the right words to say to
confront these people
the people who are going to be meeting
in dust's dreams are people who were
significant podesta before they left
town a couple of years back
and there are lots of people they don't
know quite as well too
and some people who have been shaped by
desta's impression of them in their
dreams but they've all had profound
impact on desta's life
these characters are really interesting
because all of them are interwoven as
part of dusty's story but also with each
other
they don't just appear as abstractions
but they really feel like a part of the
makeup of desti's background
one way or another the people that
destiny throughout the game helped us to
become who they are today and they've
taught us to a number of different
things like standing up for themselves
taking risks expressing themselves and
more there are a few different themes in
the story but i would say that certainly
loss is a big part of it
finding yourself courage and
perseverance and free awakening no pun
intended
it feels like we've been able to put a
lot of ourselves into desta
the same is true for pretty much all of
our games but desta in particular is
very personal to a lot of the members of
the team and i'm sure we can all relate
to some of the themes of maybe having
ghosted a friend and not being sure how
you could like get back in touch with
them or
dwelling over how you might have said
something in a conversation and like
having that play over and over in your
mind which is like one of the core
themes of the game it's definitely got
more depth and more game mechanics than
anything we've made before and it's
being designed from the ground up to be
a multi-platform title we're really
looking forward to telling you more
about destro the memories between in the
coming weeks and the coming
[Music]
months this next game is called shim uh
it's a shadow platformer you're a little
blobby character platforming around
inside shadows and a game with a really
cool minimalist graphic art style i hope
you like it
hi i'm about and i'm the developer of
skin and i'm nils from exonize and i
help avo develop skim we're located in
the north of the netherlands in a town
called leoware we are a team of two plus
the talented people at moon celebrity
audio
[Music]
[Music]
same as a game where you move around in
shadows you play as a shrimp a shadow
creature
[Music]
as a whole stream is made to be
approachable for a variety of players at
its core it's about jumping around in
shadows and platforming towards the end
of the level
[Music]
each shadow has our own skin
[Music]
the player plays around as a scream of a
human however this team is separated
from that person and it's up to you to
find your way back
[Music]
in the game you will also help others
game characters who have also been
separated from their shadow
you can help them by finding their
objects
takes big inspiration from the feeling
of playing as a child
playing imaginary games with made up
rules move around in shadows and jump to
the next shadow
[Music]
so
[Music]
check it out and follow us at
shrimpgame.com
[Music]
hi everyone and thank you deb that's
having us this year i'm and the manager
of asibu a community hub for indie game
creators in tokyo we have a space where
people can come to work and meet other
people do small gatherings and we are
helping japanese devs by introducing
them to platforms console publishers
helping them on marketing or as usually
they don't speak english helping them to
apply to overseas events like this one
and we're also doing a lot of online
contents and streams uh like our big
associated showcase which will be aired
this summer in english in japanese or a
monthly stream in the collection and
podcasts and many other things you can
check on youtube and twitch but first
let's check two really cool japanese
titles
[Music]
fox and truck travelers the demand of
arashino island is a 3d action adventure
game with a japanese-inspired atmosphere
you will play as [ __ ] her goal will
find herself on arashino island and
starts traveling with frog
[Music]
tarry gates fuso lantern and neon gives
light and color to the island but
something is lurking in the shadows
inching even clogger
[Applause]
[Music]
fox and frog travelers is developed by
rheas an illustrator and concept artist
that came up with the idea for it based
on one of his illustrations
[Music]
fox and frog long journey through the
night is planned for release in a few
years
[Music]
oh
[Music]
first game of the young solo developer
yo fuji goodbye world is a narrative
game about two young in-game creators
the shaikhani and the extrovert comedy
[Music]
mixing influences from comics like ghost
world and games like the beginner's
guide or mozzare3
goodbye world is a tale about the
passion and struggle that comes with
game creation
through 13 chapters of the story
rendered in beautiful pixel art in a
resolution close to the super nice and
gamboy advanced
[Music]
goodbye world is you out on steam later
this year if you like this game don't
hesitate to wishlist and you follow the
debt on twitter and if you are
interested by uh japanese indie scene or
indie games
you can follow us on twitter on discord
chat with us and watch our indie game
showcase which is coming this summer
and thank you again for watching and day
of the deaths for having us
[Music]
the process of moving to a new city can
be daunting our next game birth from
solo developer madison carr who hails
from chicago explores the idea of
quelling loneliness through this puzzle
adventure
hi my name is madison and i'm making a
game called birth
[Music]
[Applause]
birth is a point-and-click puzzle game
about living alone in a large city
[Music]
in order to quell your loneliness you
decide to create a creature a friend a
partner for yourself by collecting spare
bones and organs that you find while
traversing the city
[Music]
you will explore libraries and post
offices and museums and cafes and
apartments that don't belong to you
in each of these buildings you will meet
creatures and you will get to know them
by searching through their personal
belongings
their laptops and phones their cabinets
and their notebooks
[Music]
within these personal belongings there
are puzzles
some are physics-based some are
pattern-based
some are abstract
there are no instructions and you are
rarely doing the same thing twice
[Music]
alongside the main game there are
optional hidden tokens that you can find
to unlock secret buildings and treasures
[Music]
birth comes out this august i made this
game with my whole heart and i hope that
you like it
[Music]
in our next title how to say goodbye you
play as the ghost of a person who's
recently died and is embarking on the
journey of accepting their own death
the mechanics underscore the message
that there's always a way through grief
you may get stuck but you can always
stop re-evaluate and keep moving it's
all just part of the puzzle
hi i'm florian co-author of the upcoming
narrative puzzle game how to say goodbye
[Music]
in how to say goodbye you help a group
of quirky ghosts overcome various
obstacles and conundrums by reorganizing
the level as you like
[Music]
moving one tile we'll also push the
surrounding tiles
[Music]
do
[Music]
the puzzle elements are only moved
around but never removed so just like a
rubik's cube the puzzles never end up in
a state where you can't solve them
[Music]
follow various characters looking to
discover why they are still here and how
to move on while trying to escape the
grasp of an evil wizard who doesn't know
how to let go
[Music]
how to say goodbye tells a story of loss
and grief but we intend the experience
to be as gentle kind and positive as
possible
[Music]
if this sounds like something that you
would be interested in
please wishlist the game it would mean a
lot to us thank you
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
hi
well wasn't that a great show and a
great cake and it's all gone and so now
we have to say goodbye i hope you liked
that i hope you liked all the games
thank you to all the developers
for making such fantastic games and for
bringing them here for everyone to enjoy
special thanks to all of our generous
sponsors you've always been there for us
and we could not do this without you
playstation idea xbox nintendo steam
epic game store y'all are awesome
thank you extra special thanks to dos
one the magic man for supplying all the
beats and sound effects and tunes you
hear in every summer game fest edition
of day of the devs we couldn't have done
any of this without you
or at least it'd be really quiet uh and
kind of suck we're not done with the day
of the dev's 10th anniversary just yet
if you go to daythedevs.com and sign up
for our newsletter you will be amongst
the first to hear about all the
excitement that's to come this year uh
other than that thank you so much to
everybody who watched and we'll see you
next year bye
we'll see you next time
aha you thought it was over but it is
actually not day the devs continues with
a special after-party performance by the
one and only peter berkman of
onomatoguchi fame he's debuting new
music from a game you've probably never
heard of it's called little nemo and the
guardians of slumberland and the reason
you haven't heard of it is because it's
debuting on kickstarter at this
very freaking moment
enjoy see you later thanks for tuning in
to day of the devs summer game fest
edition bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the games and online harassment hotline
is a text message based anonymous and
confidential emotional support hotline
and it's created specifically for the
gaming community because we're gamers
and creators and we want to help each
other
so
how does it work
well you text us and we listen our
hotline is 100 anonymous we can talk
about anything you need to and only what
you want to
the games and online harassment hotline
is an inclusive resource for anyone no
matter how you identify if you feel that
you need emotional support you can start
right now by texting support to 23368
and our qualified responders will be
there to listen to you free of charge
reach out get help and let's make this
community a better place to work and
play